any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
if you have the cover story here it is
because i'm i'm out of the actual
physical copies maybe you have a
physical copy there of the latest issue
skeptic so uh there it is yeah in the
beginning
cosmic inflation the multiverse and the
nature of scientific proof so
when i commissioned you to do this long
i don't know many months ago now last
year actually
um you know this was before uh i even
knew that stephen meyer was writing this
book
uh the return of the god hypothesis or
that michio kaku was coming out with a
book the god equation note the
similarities of the covers
so after you finish with your galileo
book you you need to write a god book
uh and have some cover like that um so
you know the topics you cover in in the
in the cover story of skeptic
really have nothing to do with theism
and god and religion that wasn't the
purpose of it
you know i just wanted to know what's
the latest on the biggest questions
where the universe came
come came from and you know why does it
appear to be fine-tuned and and you know
what's the
the shape of the universe and what is
time and you know all those
those great questions which to me those
are scientific questions
and you're a scientist and uh but you
know it's
you don't have to dig very deep to
realize well they do have theistic
implications because you you can't help
but wonder well where did it all start
and therefore is there
something like a sentient mind behind it
all
so let's start there i mean you just had
stephen meyer on your podcast and i
listened to the whole thing it was great
conversation and so for an outsider like
me
i'm not i'm a social scientist not a
physicist so
i don't really know i kind of trust you
guys the experts to tell me
what's the latest debate and is there
consensus on
this theory or that theory or is there
no consensus and so on
so when someone like you read stephen
meyer's book that makes a you know a
really strong case for
behind it all behind the big bang behind
the fine-tuning
the cosmological constants and
and and and all that uh if
he had such a convincing argument you
know why don't you
convert that is to say why don't you go
oh yeah
he's right i i i'm now a theist and
maybe i'm even a christian
because not in his this book but right
elsewhere they
they then go from the design universe
and the designer to
you know jesus really died for your sins
and the whole thing and you become a
christian
so the fact that you and and other
professional scientists
who would read his book or his previous
books or other books by
bill dempsky and others in the
intelligent design movement
have not converted or become theists why
not
how do you know that actually i'm late
for my uh my church
i converted not only to be to be a
theist but now i am uh i converted from
judaism
to christian no i i didn't do that and
actually i told him that because he
michael that book is huge you're holding
up uh uh stephen meyer's book
and uh when he i received it in my
mailbox here at ucsd
in december mid-december or no early
december and it said dr keating i'd love
i love your work
i love it if you wouldn't consider
endorsing this book and oh by the way
it'd be great to have it by next
thursday
i was like okay at least you gave me
seven full days to read you know it's
like 80 pages a day the way that stephen
writes
i said absolutely i can't do that i'm
happy to have a conversation about maybe
doing it
but i need to have the following
conversation with you stephen i said
i have a problem with people like those
of uh your fellow
uh folks that travel in id and in
so-called
christian apologetics and that said i'm
jewish i'm a practicing jew i call
myself a devout agnostic and i can
explain what that means
but uh but the but the fact is a lot of
times i'll hear the following
set of logical syllogisms that
everything that began had a beginner
everything that began had a purpose and
therefore jesus
so in other words the universe had a
beginning uh the universe
must have had a beginner namely a god
and
therefore that god had some purpose and
therefore the god is personal
and the god also formed in the form of
the tripartite god jesus christ
to not only exist in um uh for
for the creation of the universe but
also for my own personal redemption i
said i'm a jew
i don't accept that i accept that jesus
existed i accept that he we even know
who his rabbi was
in the talmud you know there's no better
source of documentation of
ancient judea and samaria than the
talmud we know who his rabbi was we know
who that guy's rabbi was etcetera
there's no doubt that he existed the
question as to his faith claims and the
actual
theonic theoristic theistic
implications of believing in such an
entity so i said
along the way i'm going to tell you that
i read this as a cosmologist
and i find often times with william lane
craig in particular
that uh it's sort of this this it
borders on
uh confirmation bias it borders on
manipulation
of evidence to support a conclusion and
that conclusion
always ignores the existence of
alternative cosmologies
of which there are many and in this uh
article for
the cover issue of skeptic magazine this
quarter i want to flesh out the fact
that it is by no means settled that
there was
a big bang now listen i said a big bang
because it seems to me that if there
were multiple big bangs
that doesn't give more support for a
creator it might even give less support
for a creator
and i want to bring to bear the full
brunt of today's modern understanding
of theoretical cosmology and potential
alternative
stories to the genesis 1 1 narrative
which by the way michael you should know
that was resisted i'm sitting in the
office of a man by the name of jeffrey
burbidge
who passed away 10 years ago 11 years
ago jeffrey worked with fred hoyle
and they were long-term proponents of
the steady-state model until his death
in fact their number one protege one of
hoyle's foremost graduate students
his name is giant narlikar and he
lives today thankfully he's in pune in
pune india
and i interviewed him for my podcast
into the impossible and he still
believes in the steady state and he
still believes the reasons that the big
bang are believed in if you can believe
it
somewhat owes to the fact that it
comports with genesis 1
1. so listen very carefully what i'm
saying they are saying the quasi-steady
state and steady state theorists which
are the principal alternative to the big
bang
their foremost proponents believe that
my colleagues in the cosmology
wing of this university believe in the
big bang only because they're
overwhelmed
by the genesis 1 1 narrative what could
be
more kind of ludicrous to a practicing
cosmologist
and yet there are many alternatives to
this very moment
to the standard origin story that has a
single big bang and it's actually one of
the most interesting areas of cosmology
to work in
the question is can we prove it and i
thought it'd be fun to talk about proof
uh and and the limits because that's
sort of the outcome of this
discussion and and you know you say kind
of like dismissively oh i'm just a
social sign
you're much more than a social scientist
michael you understand
the currency of science revolves around
the centuries-old
scientific method which has at its core
some level of confrontation of a model
or a theory with evidence and nowadays
michael what's troubling me so much i
had on michio kaku i know you did on
your podcast
i pushed on him as a physicist you
pushed on him in really interesting ways
that kind of complemented with aliens
and with
with uh you know traversing your your
avatar at the speed of light
i thought you did a wonderful job in
ways i could not but on the cosmological
side
we are left with an essentially infinite
number of possible universes according
to both the multiverse
and string theory and i said i find this
dangerous i find it dangerous
for the scientific method yeah
interesting
um yeah just to put up an extra point on
that
someone like a stephen meyer although he
hasn't said this to me but others have
well shermer if you understood the the
quantum physics or if you knew the
equations or if you
understood inflationary cosmology which
you don't you'd see that you know i'm
right about this particular argument
well you could say that about me
and you can even say well and you're a
public atheist of course you're not
going to accept these arguments for
theism
yeah well you can't say that about you
brian keating because
you you're not a rabid militant atheist
and and you are a cosmologist
and you certainly can't say this about
say someone like
um uh the head of the
human genome project and uh and national
institutes of health um
what's his name his name just escapes me
right now no no no not francis
not francis crick um um
anybody will come to me um you know
he's an evangelical christian and he
headed the the human genome project
right
so he understands genetics and and uh
and complexity of life
or uh and so on there are theists and
atheist
cosmologists so uh in other words i kind
of lean on this
consensus theory of how science works
that
you know we're scientists who are
writing francis yeah that's right
yeah francis collins thank you
it's hell getting old anyway um
you know for the alternative when you
talk about something like you know
consensus science and climate science or
the big bang cosmology or the theory of
evolution
you know it's not like these guys are
all media on the weekends to get their
stories straight because those
intelligent designers or those
liberal democrats are going to try to
destroy american economy so they have to
have this this uh global warming thing
you know they work independently of one
another and in competition often for
grants and and journal space and so on
so they're trying to debunk each other
such that an outsider like me can go
okay the fact that they've reached
consensus is a signal to me that you
know they're probably
going along the right track here by
contrast if things are just kind of
if the steady state and big bang
theories were still kind of 50 50 and
you guys couldn't make up your mind
after 50 years i began to think i wonder
if there's a problem here
like again the string theory why i
pushed mitchie on this
topic and how can you test it uh because
you know it's
you guys have had decades and decades
and there seems to be no consensus
you know what is there a conceptual
problem here with how you're approaching
it
again i don't know anything about string
theory but i can kind of see how science
tends to work
so that's why i wanted to ask you that
you know that kind of that big question
if someone like stephen myers has such a
convincing argument
why aren't scientists going okay then
he's right we have to follow
this track maybe you don't have to
become a christian because you could
become a d or something like that
to give him his fair shake you know i i
personally don't believe many of the
people who profess to believe in
theistic explanations truly believe in
theism
uh based on behavior of of you know
people that i witnessed
not to say that i'm literally holier
than now in any case
but i think you know there's there's
such an extreme
you know almost like unconscionable
burden like i once thought like
how could a vegan brush their teeth you
know like you're killing all these
microbes and
you know it's like i think you know
radicchio out of sodium uh certainly
would apply but i think you know in
stephen's case
he you know i think he is obviously very
convinced but he also
has the intellectual honesty at least to
admit that he can't prove it
and i push back in several different
directions so one is the the lack of
unif unanimity i would say and lack of
um of a dearth in other words there are
many plausible alternatives
to the standard big bang model second of
all even the models that he
espouses in the book
sorry even the models that he espouses
in the book have
serious lacunae in them that make them
either
untestable unprovable uh unverifiable
and subject to the multiverse kind of
out paradigm
but they're they're tentative in a way
that they
cannot even be expected to have
falsifiable evidence against them
now i thought it'd be interesting for us
to talk about carl popper for a second
yeah uh you're not you're not a
physicist but you know
karl popper has enormous influence on
science
even though you know and steven actually
you know brought this out because i did
push back at one point
and we did talk about popperism and i
knew this but you know by by the
by the demarcation you know uh uh assay
by the by the statement that you can
judge if the theory is scientific
via the ability for it to be falsified
that that is the cinequan non is no
longer held by even philosophers of
science
let alone should be held by scientists i
claim that's because
that it is held sacrosanct michael i
claim that's because physicist
remember did you ever hear like well you
must have heard of penis envy
uh and i know we can we can say such
words but there's also something called
physics envy
where the some of the sciences had envy
of how rigorous physics can be
but actually i think physicists have
mathematics envy
because we cannot prove the boundaries
of what we do or do not know
in the gerdelian sense in the sense that
we don't have an incompleteness theorem
for physics because we don't prove
things i never go out and prove things
it's not what i do we just disprove
things so um
so physicists in lieu of that have
resorted to popper
of saying and they kind of have this
even though popper himself
said it's sometimes very useful for a
theory to remain untestable maybe for
some time
because it allows a hardening kind of an
annealing
of the true theory to come out my
question is
we live in reality we although many of
our listeners may not
believe that we have to get jobs
we have to get grants we have to teach
students
and in so doing we need resources and
those resources can only be allocated in
a finite sense there's a
science i always say michael lately i've
been saying this and again you've been
so influential on me
as a podcaster as a thinker and i'm you
know delighted to be a part of skeptic
now
it's funny you know having an article in
skeptic and also a
video for prager university i think
that's that might be unique although i'm
not
sure in the same month but nevertheless
um you know thinking about you know what
what
is the ultimate limit of what we do i
say nowadays
science is not an infinite it's not a
finite game
it's not as a winner takes all game
where i'm right there for michael's
wrong
and then we just go on but funding sure
is there's only so much funding
there's a finite amount of funding
there's a zero some funding and just
like there is
for uh for podcasts i mean we can only
listen to one podcast
so how do you divide your attention the
most valuable commodity of all
and how do you divide these resources
and so in reality string theory and
inflation these twin
pillars of modern day cosmological
physics
now are sort of dominant for almost 40
years
uh and to the exclusion of almost any
other paradigm receiving
funding attention and and perhaps the
resources that it needs to provide so
should it be surprising that we find
ourselves in a situation
where these are touted as proven and i
find that again kind of dangerous from
the progress in physics that i hope to
enjoy
yeah i think of uh just to close the
door of how i opened was
i think of these kinds of arguments that
intelligent design creationists make
as vastly superior to the old arguments
made by the young earth creationists say
in the 60s and 70s and
in the gish gallop when dwayne gish
would plow through 300 slides and then
give you five minutes to respond
those kinds of arguments you know these
guys have greatly improved on that
um and uh and yet i think
they're good arguments if you already
believe that is if you're already at
this
particularly if you're a christian and
you believe that uh
you know that a a sentient being of of
omniscience
and omnipotent power you know create the
universe and us and cares about us and
so on
all these arguments are pretty good i
mean it's like yeah yeah they're very
reinforcing
in a in a bayesian kind of way i already
believe so i'm piling up more and more
confirmatory evidence for my beliefs
and then to to the bayesian thing i
think preparing falsification is just
one element of
science scientists do reason in a
bayesian way where you guys are trying
to
update your priors so you run an
experiment and the experiment comes out
one way or the other
if it comes out in a positive way that
that kind of ups your
your prior to the credence of your
theory being
true true with a small t uh no
no capital t's and i think what's
particularly confusing to a lot of us
again outsiders is that the areas you
working in
that you work in are so um sort of
abstract
or you know non-concrete so
i'm going to read something to you here
from stephen pinker uh that he wrote me
in a in a
in a little group email after i had
michiokaku on the podcast couple my
cycling friends who listened to the
podcast emailed me
commenting on what i just said this
stuff is also abstract you know higgs
boson and the
inflationary this and the flatness of
the universe or what
what you know and so uh and so steve
made
this observation which you know he's
just so so good at this
sort of thing um he says it seems to me
that any ultimate theory in fundamental
physics is going to be hard to test
because at some point we're bound to ask
questions that just happen to be
inconvenient or impossible for mortal
humans to study
for practical reasons for example you
can't build a particle accelerator the
size of the solar system
but the universe wasn't created for the
benefit of scientists and it may be our
bad luck that we don't have the means to
build labs to test every theory
that's when elegance parsimony
consistency
scope etc are the only criteria we can
apply
and then he makes a comment because we
we also discuss the nature of
consciousness
it also seems inevitable that any level
of depth the theory is going to look
pretty abstract
almost vindicating a kind of idealism
where the only reality is the math here
sorry i'm still continuing with the
abstract physics
one wouldn't expect a theory to add a
note at the end of its equation
oh and there are 80 bitty little tiny
bits of hard stuff out there
corresponding to the seventh term of
equation 39.
and then he says as a cognitive
scientist i'm always mystified by claims
that
consciousness can only be explained by
some highly abstract or
counter-intuitive or obtruse
theory in physics that would be called
for if esp existed
but as michael has documented for
decades it doesn't
100 of consciousness depends on photons
striking rods and cones vibrating sound
pushing against ear drums neurons
transmitting chemicals across synapses
in computational networks etc
if consciousness is sourced directly
from fields here he's referring to like
quantum fields
based on one theory why do we have to
turn on the lights and open our eyes to
see
such a great comment so here i'm
wondering you know are we at a point you
guys you physicists theoretical
physicists and commodities we're
you're just kind of bumping up against
the wall of all we have now is math
because we can't really test these super
abstract theories well there i've got
good news and good news
because actually we can test the uh
alternatives to say inflation which
produce produces this
you know resplendent extravagant
multiverse and the cosmological so i
should say
let me take a step back there's two
different types of multiverses
at minimum that physicists talk about um
and one of the which is uh is one of the
cosmological sense that just as we have
multiple planets
we have multiple stars and galaxies etc
there are multiple
universes so that's just the evolution
of the cosmological principle the
copernican principle
so that's something that almost seems um
it almost seems natural that there
should be other universes and of course
there's nothing even in the bounds of
ordinary cosmology
that precludes there being a universe
right next door as
some you know one quipped once you know
there's a heck of a universe right next
door let's go
um but there could be a universe that's
literally you know one light day
away from our observable universe's
boundary the
the light cone from which we can receive
information during the next day
and we'll find out about it splash
across the front page of the new york
times tomorrow the
the the santa barbara news press or the
union tribune
um there's another type of multiverse
which is uh that there are universes
separated in space
and or in time and they're separated in
many different ways
by uh by not only their differing
or physical phenomena that take place in
other words
there could be so many that you know i
host a podcast called the the brian
keating show and you host one called the
into the impossible podcast
on the other hand uh there could be
universes where there's six dimensions
of space in one of time
there could be universes where the speed
of light is slower than our speed of
sound
etc etc so there are limits by the way
to the existence of life forms like
ours in the so-called week anthropic
principle sense
but let me ask this question i i've been
thinking about this one a lot because i
don't think this
has really been addressed i asked
michiokaku about this
and i said you guys always who talk
about the string multiverse which is the
latter
form of the multiverse that i just spoke
about you always talk about that as
having you know the different mass of
the proton
the speed of light the nuclear force
will change a little bit but what's to
prevent the laws of logic
that modis tollins applies or not in
another universe it seems to me that
if you can let everything change and
that two plus two could be five in
another
in another universe then it's basically
hopeless because in that case you could
never potentially
test the non-existence or prove the
non-existence
of such a universe because we would not
only lack
the experimental tools you know what
stephen pinker's talking about
is enhancements to our own sensors so
i did a podcast with deepak chopra and
leonard milad now
and i talked about uh we talked about
like i called it sensors and sensibility
you know it's like what we see is what
we interact with and then you know
michael's claiming that we don't have
any free will because everything's for
ordained in the
in the uh wave function of the universe
whatever that means
and then deepak saying no there's all
this quantum decoherence and
and it's like yeah grudgingly i have to
say you know both of them are right and
both of them are wrong
the problem is we don't observe the
universe
outside the universe we are observing it
from within
and so we are subject to certain basic
tenets and
the lack of our ability to gauge the
existence of another universe
may be due to physical limitations
namely the finite speed of light
the finite age of the observable
universe etc so
i think of these as cosmic chicken or
egg problems in other words
which came first you know the the
universe or the laws of physics because
if you ask lawrence krauss who's going
to be a guest
um coming up on my podcast for his
climate change book
um i'm uh you know if you ask him you'll
say oh the laws of physics
you know and the lincoln theorem which
uh he popularized in his book
called a universe from nothing suggests
that the universe can emerge
you know from this uh this balance
between negative energy and positive
energy
canceling out so zero means nothing
means it can come from nothing
no that's not actually correct that's
not an interpretation that even
valencian recognized
it's merely this the statement that
there had to be a pre-existing
universe in the sense of the laws of
quantum mechanics the laws of
mathematics etc what stephen meyer gets
into
is that only such things that have
boundary conditions what we call in
physics if you look at a pendulum
swinging back and forth michael you
can't tell me
where i started the bob of the pendulum
you can't tell me because you don't know
the initial conditions you just know the
total energy in the system but you don't
know the initial conditions
similarly you have to know the boundary
conditions of a system you have to know
well what volume is it contained within
and what are the interactions of the
measurement apparatus on the subject
being measured
so for all these reasons i find it very
difficult to
to glean from uh the current book that
we're discussing with stephen myers book
that because the universe started in low
entropy
as many people if not all people believe
that that is evidence of
order because that presupposes a
pre-existing pre-order
and so i asked him i said michael why i
said to michael i said stephen
why is it that if you were alive
michael in the very early universe apart
from the first three minutes
the next billion or so years would have
been the most boring
you know in recorded history almost
nothing have hydrogen formed over here
that's about it for hundreds of millions
of years and then
if you just think about us as our dna
dna didn't emerge for a very long time
at least on earth we don't understand
exactly when the first humans that look
like us so in other words
everything was created by this mind with
a purpose
according to you stephen and yet why was
there
you know billions of years waiting
between events in other words
the clock you could have like looked
back and forth and if you look every
billion years or so you'd say this is a
pretty slow universe
he didn't have an answer for that he
said you know god can create the
hubble deep field he can create anything
he wants yeah
so i found that very unsatisfying
satisfaction
i'm surprised he didn't come up with
something like this which i've heard
that is to say to an eternal
deity uh you know what difference does
it make is 14 billion or 14 trillion
eternity goes way
past that so you know whether it's 10
years
10 million years 10 billion years 10
trillion years they're just
they're just zeros after the one and to
an eternal being that doesn't mind that
you have a puppy right
i have a puppy i have a dog yeah
you have a dog so you got that dog when
you're in your 50s or whatever
like you could ask the same question
like i waited uh it's not it's not the
duration
that you that you demurred from making a
decision or making a phenomenon
instantiate itself
it's the it's the the relevant time
scale is the time scale and when that
thing
started to take action and have effect
that you as the designer if you will of
that dog's particular life
had a purpose for it in other words
intelligence
you know there are things that can
appear intelligent but they actually
convey no
real information to us right it's
patterns like a license plate like
simon's famous
license plate yeah on the way over this
lecture i saw the following license 6q7
or tv oh that's intelligent no it's not
it is absolutely meaningless it was
created by an intelligence
but so too with your dog i would say
what
the purpose of your life up to getting
that dog was getting the dog
which it would seem to be if we are the
pinnacle of creation which i can
actually
take some stock in for practical reasons
not me personally but
but nevertheless why wait so long why
create so many uh
different universes your point is that
if if it's all here for us
why wait 14 13.8 billion years or
13.7 i guess you know to create uh life
forms and so on
um yeah well i have the same problem too
as well as this problem which i want to
ask him about
and he started to go down that path but
then he kind of changed the subject
that is how does the deity the
intelligent designer how does god do all
this stuff
and and i would push it i would push it
even even more than this
you know it's the same problem that
descartes started uh with a dualistic
uh world view how does mind interact
with the stuff
like to to ghost hunters i always ask
them how does the ghost
know to turn right at the hallway and
open the door and
and how does the ghost knock the picture
off the wall
the you know the ghost is supposedly
this non-material substance it's the
same problem we have with
consciousness how does a thought cause
my muscles to move
well you know the synapses you know and
in the in the neurons fire and so yeah
but but how does the thought cause the
neuron to fire
well other neurons are firing right yeah
those are just physical systems
if you impute behind that a mind how
does the mind
interact with the physical stuff and so
i would just ask you know
like if god is performing miracles how
does he do it
does he you know reach into the cells
and and let's say cure that
mary's cancer does he go into every cell
in the tumor
and reprogram it so that it dissolves
and the tumor gets smaller
it's exactly how does this happen and
you know the only answer you're going to
get is well god works in mysterious ways
or nobody knows
or that's an unanswerable question or i
don't know what uh
at some point similarly to push back
yeah
oh go ahead no no good that's it
yeah so so the yeah exactly my my
feeling uh you're echoing
beautifully michael but i also can push
back because i've heard cox by
say you know sean carroll and sean will
say things like well
god is not a good theory he of course is
too smart to say there is no god i can
prove it
he'll say the probability of god is less
than a few
tenths of a percent but the probability
of the multiverse he puts at 50 50
and it depends on what multiverse i
think he believes the multiverse in the
everetti and many worlds
uh conception is is a hundred percent he
believes that is the correct
interpretation of quantum mechanics
but nevertheless just thinking
cosmological multiverse and i'll say to
him well what is the evidence for that
well he says well
god could and should produce the
simplest most parsimonious
universe first and that um and that
would be a empty universe
in other words the fact that our
universe has stuff in it stuff that can
think of things
is now evidence that god is at least not
parsimonious
and i say to him well and he says yeah
just look at the hubble deep field
and i said to him i said well sean you
know he's like look at all those
galaxies
you know even if there is life there we
can never interact with it and therefore
it's it's pointless to our existence on
earth
so we cannot be you know most people
think that galileo showed we were not
the center of the solar system
he didn't do that he just showed that
there are other rightful places that
could claim to be the center of the
universe
and that was enough to at least disprove
the thought that we were the center of
the universe right
so it's so he said well those galaxies
over there have no purpose to us and if
we are the pinnacle of creation
it can't be so that those other things
uh exist for any purpose
that matters to us because they don't do
anything for us and i said well sean the
same thing could have been said about
uranium
in the year 18 you know 42. they didn't
know about uranium
and they didn't know about quantum
mechanics and all these four and by the
way two weeks ago i had on my podcast
uh someone discussing the a new
potential fifth force of nature
discovered at the large hadron collider
that's a force we didn't know about
until 2021
if it holds up which it may or may not
but the point is that we can uh we don't
not yet know the purpose for many things
that scientists discover
and again i'm pushing back as the theist
and i said to i said to
you know to sean i have uh my upstairs
professor colleague she studies that
galaxy
over there in the hubble deep field and
his response was oh come on
you can't be serious like i was like
that's a purple like i've just provided
you one particular person
in the universe for whom that serves a
purpose and you're saying that's not
that's
doesn't qualifies well so too does the
evidence for
the pre-existing hilbert space that
contains an empty universe
in quantum mechanics that sean uh
believes in that is
is enough to refute the existence of a
designer who had a purpose for us
specifically
so i found i find you know i i like to
give people grief on both sides michael
i don't know is there
is there a name for my condition i like
to like push back on both the theists
and the atheists well
i think that makes me well you're i'm
not sure yeah what is a uh what do you
call it
militant agnostic i don't know and you
don't either something like that is that
what you are
how do you define your how do you define
agnosticism
yeah so i define agnosticism again
similar you once told me you don't call
yourself an atheist usually because that
means you're defining you by what you're
not
so i shouldn't define myself by what i'm
not but i will say that i know what like
michio kaku
is not i know what uh the late great
friend of mine freeman dyson was not
in other words they would not go to the
same
church that richard dawkins does not go
to
and so there was no functional way for
an intelligent alien
if such exists to look at michiokaku and
distinguish him functionally
from uh from our friend richard dawkins
right so there's no way to tell in
practice
which one is which and so we know that
we are the sum of a lot of
what impacts us our behavior i think
you're a behaviorist to some
level i certainly am and i believe that
you know behavior is a manifestation of
what our worldview is
and so michio doesn't go to church and
and uh
and he may say that he's agnostic but i
kind of feel i
wonder i hope it's not true um that he
is like stephen hawking you know stephen
hawking put things like the mind of god
at the end of his brief history of time
and so does michio kaku
and i think sometimes that's to not turn
off theists and and i i hope that's not
the case for
for michio at least i know it was for
hawking but um i'm actually having
you'll like this guy i'll i'll send him
over your way if you're interested
charles seif at nyu
who wrote zero the birth of a dangerous
he just wrote a book called
hawking hawking and it's about the
business of stephen hawking
and how he was kind of clever that's
clever
it's the first critical biography of
stephen hawking as opposed to all the
hate geography that exists around him
and one of the pieces of geography was
that he was you know he was a kind man
and he didn't care people believed in
god
he was pretty militant in all of his
books that god did not exist and he
could prove it
and his way to prove it michael was one
inflation
to invalidate the need for god to
establish the universe
and two string theory what's called m
theory which is what michio describes
and that was to instantiate the laws of
physics and neither one of which
is held as proven or ever could be
thanks to even the discussions according
even to their proponents
such as alan guth and michio kaku here
is what
leonard milan now writes in his memoir
of stephen
hawking so here he is leonard is quoting
stephen
who typed this out to him a law is not a
law if you allow god to intervene
he said that leaves two possible roles
for god
one is to choose the initial condition
of the universe we got rid of that with
the no boundary proposal
i wrote about that in a brief history of
time
the other possible role is for god to be
responsible for choosing the laws
and making a universe based on those
laws it shall arise in the last chapter
of our book
that it is not necessary to invoke god
for this either
he's referring to the grand design that
they wrote together
he hawking continues i want to make my
position clear without being violently
anti-religion like richard dawkins he
continued
i have just been sent his book the god
delusion
if you want to see it get judith i agree
with most of it but i don't think it is
necessary to be so
aggressive and then at the end of the
memoir
in the closing pages here leonard
recalls the day that that book came out
the grand design
and steven's secretary or assistant
whoever calls leonard
and says have you seen the time she
asked the new york times i said yes i'd
read it
not the new york times the london times
haven't you seen it
and leonard says judith who here reads
the london times
well google it look at the headline it
says quote hawking
god did not create the universe it's
creating a furor
then leonard continues that's wrong i
said we said god isn't necessary for
creating the universe not that physics
proves he didn't
well the press is all over and stephen
can't handle it all we need your help
you need to do some interviews so you
know he's basically saying
you know don't put hawking in the same
category with with richard dawkins in
terms of how militant
well but he is but i mean he was he you
know in this book by charles scythe
professor seif
really makes the case that he cultivated
that image but he was
much more kind of calculating behind the
scenes those two things
that he talks about a brief history of
time in a grand design those
are accepted a hundred percent by the
public and almost zero percent by
practicing physicists
really so it's a total sales drop that
absolutely well inflation is not it's
not
essentially it's not provable in the
sense that you could only
you know you can't you can't falsify it
as we said earlier
you cannot show evidence that's
inconsistent with inflation
if inflation could have existed so for
example
let's say that there's evidence a
evidence a will occur
for inflation enough to provide
supporting evidence for it
and if evidence a occurs that means you
can reasonably infer in a bayesian sense
that inflation took place
well there's a couple things that could
happen one inflation didn't happen
in which case you won't see evidence a
but also it could be that
that inflation did take place but it did
so in a way
as to provide noisy enough data that you
can never
detect it with confidence level greater
than one so in that case you'd be in
this no man's land and it becomes a
matter of taste that's
that applies to the inflationary
component that was he brought out
and actually he didn't play a huge role
in inflation
and this book makes out a big point that
hawking would write papers with people
in this case he wrote a paper with my
colleague at uc santa barbara named
james
hartle the no boundary proposal and in
that
i believe that they probably did are
hawking
he would write papers and people would
say yeah i'll be on the paper with you
because it's going to get a thousand
times more citations than if i write it
by myself
knowing that hawking would take all the
credit for it actually andy strominger
is quoted in this book who's a
renowned professor at harvard saying
that in his last paper in 2017 or so
he made that calculation and he decided
to go with it even though he knew he'd
be written out of the
history books for credit um but in the
context of the of the no boundary
proposal
if you read the book as i did recently
and and again
i tried to read it when i was 18 when it
came out i couldn't understand it
now i'm a practicing cosmologist like
not only is it like not i don't say
trivial
but it's it's simple for me and i'm not
a theoretical cosmologist by the way i'm
an experimental cosmologist
but i was simple enough for me to know
that he made a very very
almost uh disingenuous trick in that
book
and that was in in in the calculation
where he talks about
time not having a beginning and there
being nothing north of the north pole
and that being a stupid question he
makes what
what stephen meyer points out is an
exact accuracy
he makes a mathematical approximation he
converts
the time domain into what's called
imaginary time
which it doesn't have a physical
existence cannot be measured it's merely
a mathematical trick if you remember
anything about imaginary numbers the
imaginary numbers are the square root
of negative numbers which shouldn't
exist according to
um you know normal experience with
numbers we don't have a number that's
the
that's the square root of negative 2.
such thing doesn't exist but when you
introduce a negative uh
square root of negative one such things
can exist hawking does that and he says
i'm gonna do a little mathematical trick
but it's just a trick and then later on
it goes because of that trick
now we know the time is imaginary and
time could start with no beginning
whatsoever
just like there's no beginning of the of
the earth's surface it's so
disingenuous and and the worst possible
read of it and best
it's like a convenience it's like saying
i'm going to do like some mathematical
you know gibberish here and then at the
end i'm going to say i'll make a
conclusion
but i'll go back and i'll remind you i
still have to address that he never
addressed that
and so that is not accepted by almost
any working cosmologist today the this
the first book the brief history of time
and i ask you
did you come away from your conversation
with kaku being convinced that string
theory or m
theory is correct and that's why we have
the laws it's basically the anthropic
principle
saying there's an infinite number of
universes infinite because the vacuum of
string theory the lowest possible energy
state that a theory can have
is completely undefined within the
theory and here's where i don't like
what kaku does
kaku says well it's not fair to ask
that we test string theory today because
we don't know
it's principles in final form i know
that you're not a physicist but you know
for sure
that we don't have a final theory of
quantum mechanics either right
we don't have we have we have
interpretations we have principles
but you know you and i wouldn't be
talking if we didn't have the laws of
physics that govern quantum behavior
to produce the transistors in the screen
that you and i are conversing through
so it's very different you can't say
that the lack
of a underlying principle is a deterrent
an impediment to getting something
useful like a transistor that produces
an image on a screen
because we have examples where such
things occur we don't understand the
principles that govern them
at their most basic behavior so i think
that is not
an honest assessment of why we should
not why we should abandon
the 400 year old scientific method i
came away highly unconvinced
interesting yeah i guess i am too in
that version of the multiverse the
string theory
version if i'm getting that right where
there's somewhere there's a version of
you and i
almost exactly the same in which i have
more hair than you instead of vice versa
and that that just seems pretty but your
hair bills michael that's what i did
it seems pretty pretty ridiculous okay
it seems more likely
if there's a multiverse that uh you know
it's these
other universe other bubble universes
unconnected to ours
but then the theaters could could uh
reasonably
uh retort like we do to them uh you know
you need to be more specific in step two
here referring to the sydney harris
cartoon with the two mathematicians at
the
two scientists at the chalkboard with
the masses of equations and then and
then a miracle happens in the middle
you know that we're accusing them of
saying you're just making this leap of
faith
there's no evidence for this you just
believe in it you're just asserting it
and they could then come back to
something like this untestable
string theory uh you're just making this
up this multiverse thing
now but but to to make a slight uh
point here to ask you this question
because myers makes this point as do
other
intelligent designers you guys just made
up this multiverse to avoid the
inevitable conclusion that a deity is
behind it all
and as i understand it that's not where
the multiverse comes from it comes out
of the equations or it's it's
derivative of some mathematics or
something like that
in other words you weren't sitting
around going oh crap we're going to have
to say that there's a god and i don't
want that
so i'm going to make up this stuff about
the multiverse
well right so so exactly it's funny
because these
are relatives of the so-called
copernican principle
so in the i think it was the 500th
anniversary of copernicus's birth
uh there was a um there was a kind of a
fest shrift a party held for copernicus
in uh krakow or yeah and so um
there there were scientists i think it's
brandon carter who came up with this
proposal that he called the anthropic
principle
that is sort of you know so the
anthropic principle stands kind of
opposite from the
uh from the copernican principle so it's
kind of ironic birthday gift
to get for uh for old uh nicholas
but nevertheless the the multiverse uh
emerges uh from different phenomena
than the string theory that's actually
true so i would say
string theory contains within it a more
natural multiverse
which is called the landscape in the
language of string theory
then does cosmology in the inflationary
multiverse because
if if inflation took place
you can have inflation without a
multiverse but you can't have string
theory without some form of a landscape
in other words there's more prolific
more extravagance
in the landscape of string theory than
the landscape of inflation
and part of the proof of that is that
you can have string inflation
so you know what's better than chocolate
or peanut butter right
uh you put them all together and in the
case of you know the string theory it's
sort of even bigger in the sense that
inflation can occur
continuously for all eternity whatever
that means
in the multiverse and that produces an
infinite number by virtue of the fact
that given
uh you know a finite probability uh to
create a universe per unit time times an
infinite time you'll produce
infinite numbers of universes but in the
string theory
it's actually impossible to put in what
the
what this you know initial condition or
boundary conditions are
for the uh for the vast possibility
of in in quantum mechanical states that
string theory could could produce
the problem for me as a practicing
cosmologist who doesn't you know is open
to either
scenario is that well what if it is true
that we live in a multiverse
um so in that case you know is there any
predictive power
like can you can you even use as i said
earlier the laws of logic i mean
if if there's a prop 100 probability
that we exist
in some other universe um and we're
doing opposite things etc like hair or
podcast names or whatever
then um then then there is no prior in
other words
is basically everything can happen
that's not mathematically well defined
in other words something that's
mathematically well defined should be
subject to a a computer could solve it
another but computers can't solve things
that are unbounded you get this not a
number like n-a-n
um which i used to think was like nana
but it's not it's uh
it means not a number and so you
computers can't handle it and so
either the universe is not computable in
that we can't
encapsulate the full complexity of the
universe on a computer
or uh the problem is ill-defined in that
you have a measure a mathematical term
of a density
of probability that has no is
ill-defined
in other words it has it doesn't operate
in the normal laws of probability
and for that reason i think it is true
that it could be
construed as almost hopeless like if i
tell you michael you're the chief of the
nsf
and i said this to kaku the other day i
said you know you've got um
you've got string theory on one hand and
you've got um
you've got you know effective quantum
quantum field theory on another you've
got string
theory and some alternative to it called
effective field theory
or eric weinstein has a geometric unity
et cetera et cetera you can only fund
one you know what do you do
you're the director of the national
science foundation oh i think
i think you should give it to both but
in this case you
maybe if you agree with him that would
be a huge raise for alternatives to
string theory
and a huge huge you know tax on strength
theory
because it's basically almost in every
physics department in the in the country
there's someone who understands and and
works on string theory
and there's people that you know that
believe in string cosmology
and so this is where it gets very
dangerous and i think you know people
like lee smolin and others have written
on this extensively
that physics has stagnated in a lot of
ways fundamental physics not not
other particle physics has stagnated we
haven't come up with a unified
theory of you know so-called gravity uh
unified with other theories
although by the way michael you know
people are really um obsessed with the
theory of everything
right the t-o-e but there's actually
another theory that we also don't know
uh and that's called the grand unified
theory and
my my point and that's where the laws of
the nuclear force
the electromagnetic force and the weak
nuclear force
combined together uh into one force the
same way that electricity and magnetism
unify into one force
and then the theory of everything are
those three forces married to the
gravitational force
and that creates a theory so we're kind
of looking past the goal lines right now
we're kind of like celebrating in the
end zone we haven't discovered a theory
of grand unification yet
and yet we're kind of obsessed with
string theory as the theory of
everything
so and you know i just wonder if we're
not putting you know descartes before
the horse
[Music]
yeah so the question is is it just a
really hard problem
and along the lines of what steve pinker
commented we just don't have a solar
system size
particle accelerator to figure out which
is the right theory
in a test therefore um we're just kind
of making speculations or
have you guys all gone down the wrong
path string theorists whatever
gone down the wrong path and and there
was that book
like 10 years ago called not even wrong
i forget the author's name
um basically he was saying string theory
yeah he did
yeah so that string theory is just
completely off the rails and
and you gotta try something completely
different
so um we actually have a particle
accelerator the size of the universe
uh it's funny when people say things
like oh you just we just need a bigger
particle accelerator
you know 10 years ago michael if i told
you um would you like a particle
accelerator that takes 10 to the 80th or
10 to the 20th
nuclei and smashes them together uh two
of them together at the speed of light
you know maybe
90 percent the speed of light you say
hell yeah that would be awesome
and it's called you know a coalescing
neutron star
you know binary neutron star merger and
we detect them every day with with
ligand right
so it's like people think too small we
actually have the most advanced
interesting
we have a particle accelerator that
excel it's galactic size it's called a
cosmic ray detector
we also have a potential detector of
primordial waves of gravity which i talk
about in this month's article in this
quarter's article
which is that we are looking for what is
called the polarization of the cosmic
microwave background radiation
and if we find a particular type of
pattern of polarization
that would be indicative that not that
the inflationary theory is right
but the alternatives are wrong so it's
actually a lot more helpful than pinker
would lead us to believe
in that we can actually make crisp
falsification
type tests but not of the dominant
paradigm
so that's the interesting thing there's
no way to test the dominant paradigm as
far as we could tell
and even by their own admission even by
the of the allen goops and the
andre lindes we cannot test uh the
theory because any
any time and as um there's one of the
founders of string theory
are one of the um greatest contributors
of string theory
um who work with ed whitton on the
so-called cyborg whitten equations
his name was is nathan cyberg he's at
the institute for advanced study
and he says most string theorists are
very arrogant he said with a smile
if there is something beyond string
theory we will call it string theory
so it's but the alternatives are not
that's not the case
we falsified the steady state we can
falsify
the bouncing you know kind of re
visitations reincarnations of steady
state
and uh but we can't prove or even
falsify
the inflationary or string theory
landscape proposals
so you know i ask you well you're
putting on your good bayesian hat if i
tell you that
all these other things are falsified you
know what
what prior do you ascribe to the
dominant paradigm that's one question
the other one is if they're getting all
the money like would you expect an
alternative cosmology
like paul steinhardt and neil turock
discussed
or would you expect roger penrose even
winner of this year's nobel prize in
physics
would you expect that they would have as
much attention
as the dominant paradigm even though the
other paradigm is not
is not testable in a falsification sense
in other words if you were just an
intelligent funding director you might
say
well i'm going to put some money in the
thing i can at least prove wrong
not all of my eggs in one or all of my
dollars in one basket to be proven
possibly right or confirmed interesting
so you're
you're saying perhaps string theory is
the dominant theory
uh is it has gone down the wrong path
and that we should shift some funding
over to these other areas
it's not clear that every incremental
dollar uh that you put into string
theory would have as much
impact as exploring alternatives or
you know thinking of tests that could
potentially prove it it's not clear that
it's hurting for funding
put it that way yeah it's certainly not
hurting for publicity right i mean it's
certainly not hurting for popularity
and publicity well this is michigan's
book it's
it's it hangs on string theory well
we'll see
if you like this video please let me
know what you thought in the comments
[Music]